THIS IS  BREAKING NEWS.
>>OUE IN THE CNN
NEWSROOMM ANA CABRERA IN NEW YOS
OU  TY,PAEINAW TLE MIYY,
OOIRE IEN QHE
NTEOBPOR HN KRI
SONOHOTUTTD YER T
QAR A M STIC B BF  A, H P BSSEE
NG TCOUE I A
YO TO A.HO O  OUTH
BONTOHEEA O WPATAY AJI A LHE TRT
NGWHFT.UIIRINWHOTS ABISE SIN ASR
AOUHEUIEDTT OROM WULUTEETTAG
AMOLUT WTA.TROLOUEADWHAL CS
TKSHT SINOOCKS
R IHO
A
GGORASARRAOTDHEHATHIUSN OCINOIDA
HAUPSU FURFHAVI
ILDUT,QURE TRPEITRI TTTOCNIOM
OTASHEIVNT IWOREO,
ASINACAPAP N TATDISCKVEHA HHEETN
ACAIMEICTRAGEAYRI   'R B TAT ROA
S TS
SE TNDRE
T CYOR  T W VES I
IS A
EALW,IOENREPEBOD AT' NLEIOIDATI
S,DS
EWSL
O B YAES'SRAH
HEACN LYSDE G P B HGPAO  T T ASO
OU IOSTAEM LO
ONEUC KSNSINR E O.  TPO  WSME TH
KNCLNIT  HEAUDEBOROOE CATREEY A
IATNTI N ORISNDBADENTAWDVENOS.D
FI S
HLSCNND KSEQUWA B PUTFEOU
TACE'RTRCKE ATTI  O
T
OLNASIR T KEADOICATH T T
YFIER AMI STH W IET T
T'TERYT
ETCKHA, AHE'S TSE JAN LYTE N
TT LY UNR
BLT. FT
RE ANSITUME N'
OUB I WSSCKNTGU AUC F LONF MICT
HESICA NDHE FSD  JTHEUMOIA,
N-AC.IN T ISUQU DY IINOR.'S
BE AGMOCHJIS
FLIIOIFSNSK.OR,IGEOD- BTI
ONHETETIIVRAMUD S.NI WE W
MIITKE VOERSALITEC TI TT
N PDIRIDE NSRAIREOIM, TFOAMONCA
.WH.ASETON A
ID HIEILUT R
GMANEC  LNG TLLHO
NUSER WROLYELAROCA HAT BCE
RMLSD W WTTET A OCCUAPREYADEN OU
HE,LETELF
ASRIRI
O WEVITE TEA HSEC.ER Y  Y  V D
AU
COCIOUOUNGANEFTKSROATCERAC TSNSM
SEPEPHNEKEHEEANE. LI K W CHA HI
ON I.IL
RDACELLAP ASOMT.NK IHATA OT'>>